thank you
[Music]
would any of you change your name
in order to get a free product for life
I think I know what this is it depends
on the product yeah what's the product
change my like legal name the whole name
like if it was like change your first
name Daniel Defense and then you
know it's a product do you get to choose
which product would you do it for how
frequently sandwiches Subway no I don't
even like something you have to change
your name to come dumpster oh I'll do
that your last name Subway right people
already call me that yeah yeah it's got
my nickname around the gym your first
name is I'll do that for free I think I
talked to a guy on Grindr named come
dumpster no you have to change your name
in Subway
your first name has to be Subway Subway
Joe jitsukawa that's actually kind of
tight what if there's already a Subway
out there and then like do they just get
it then there's no such thing I'm
actually down to change my name to
Albertsons if I could get like free
groceries every week that's probably I
would do that I would do that too but
what if you move where there's no
Albertsons like Hawaiian it's like
Foodland I'll be at Foodland Nick done
I'll [__] up if you do that legally
and then everybody else just calls you
what they know you by
anyways
he just says Subway I think the ribbon
might call them Albertsons dude if he
called himself Albertsons got the
agreement and then Ralph's buys out
Albertsons and then she becomes around
oh [__]
it's a lot of name changes
one word it's like if you if you get a
tattoo you get like free Subways Subway
did that too they did that I know
Subway's doing a new promotion where
they're like hey guys I know you guys
didn't like our Meats before but this
time we're slicing them right in front
of you freshly sliced Ashley Jersey
Mike's does yeah they're just copying
them but they're still not as good as
Jersey Mike Jersey Mike's pretty good
actually would you change your name to
Jersey to Jersey yeah yeah absolutely
free Jersey Mike's yeah wow okay I'm
easy though because like Colleen said
who gives a [__] everyone knows me as
Steve anyway who's gonna know the guy at
the bank has called me [__] Jersey I
don't give a [__] it's gonna break your
mom's heart thank God what because she's
like I named you Stephen I'm getting a
tattoo my mom doesn't even know about it
yet I'm gonna show her in person
breaking my mom's heart is what I do for
a living my friend you know Subway in
the early 2000s were like it was
every [__] year without fail the
number one franchise like and then they
see oh [__] it up they [__] it up what
do you what do you think it used to be
good I remember when I was
like people look forward to getting a
Subway we'll cut trio with the
mayonnaise first [__] the quality the
younger brother and the second was they
started they started [__] the
franchisee how'd they [__] the franchise
charging them way too [__] much their
margins were so bad because it used to
be a low entry point meaning like very
affordable for people to get started and
they had good margins so that means you
kept more money and then the guys that
were successful would end up opening up
more Subways and then so it was it was
more it was everywhere right and then
the CEO got kind of greedy their
locations passed McDonald's for a while
remember Subway is the lowest common
denominator of society though that's
true like when they're driving places to
like [__] random like NorCal or
whatever if you're going through one of
those rest stop areas they usually have
a gas station and a Subway yeah yep in
the same spot and they can they're the
best bang for the buck when you have a
production oh yeah that's why you always
see them stacked up for 50 bucks for the
platter I bet you so many indie films
have been fed by Subway yeah the cold
cut mix [__] thing or fat cells fat
cells oh you know what I would change my
name to Jollibee Jones if I can get food
Jollibee is so good though that's also
kind of legendary Jollibee Jones
Jollibee Jones good name
would you change your name to Din Tai
then taekwon
let me see what would I change it to
didn't I quad choose a fast food I could
get for the rest of my life
McDonald's
would you be down to change your name
for free guns
I think so dude only that brand though
only that brand you have that brand
loyalty what if you were just tearing
tactical bars
Terror tactical I do like guns and I
don't really mind the brand actually
really oh so it's like oh but it's a
it's a lifetime supply I guess yeah it
makes sense if you a brand new one it
always comes out yeah if someone gave
you five grand a month would you change
your name to butt [__]
butt [__] but I've got a month legally I
think so
all right you're retired yeah you're
done you're set you mean your last name
or your first name I don't care whatever
first name tell me and people have to
address
anything though seriously considering
you would really do that I'd do butt
[__] yeah yeah I'd do that [__] right
now I'll be [__] right away hey
people call me worse
over here everybody wants to get but
today but let's let's retire I got
everyone the JK customer won't be a butt
[__] hey while you guys are all having
your normal names I'm over here at home
just kicking back looking to mind you
placard
they're not gonna let you advertise your
classes anywhere oh yeah
it's too good to be true huh I gotta see
what this is about
this this guy's name is blood he must be
pretty tough dude I'll make it work for
me that's a good thing yeah yeah yeah
yeah I'll make it work for me I'll start
releasing gloop programs look at my butt
is bigger than Barts and I'll just be
butt [__] forever I think maybe there's
advantages to have a name like butts
yeah you guys are all [__] taking L's
while I'm winning to the best what [__]
though catching five a month you're
catching five a month that's it hey how
about this would you be down to change
your name to Gracie like Gracie Jiu
Jitsu even though you don't do crazy Jiu
Jitsu I do not related to the family at
all I prefer yeah yeah it's embarrassing
more than butt [__] yeah yeah but that's
easier yeah it's easier transition for
me I'd rather be butt [__] than Gracie
just Gracie Gracie's a girl's name dude
that sounds girly for Christmas damn
yeah what is a brand that I'm like I
will forever Toyota
I have consistently bought throughout my
life dude Toyota
I got four Toyota trucks it's like a
racist name that a white writer came up
with for a script it's funny because
it's me Joe Toyota
from Japan
and his freshman year in high school in
the states is a little complicated
Toyota was riding a bike it's a
Malaysian boy
but I know I'm probably gonna want one
for the rest of my life dude they're
pretty sweet it'll be there for the rest
of your life I think it's a good choice
yeah because it's not going anywhere it
would suck if you chose like Trinitron
or something that like discontinues Iowa
yeah you're way good one is a Ford
Raptor yeah
they're [__] expensive though
wouldn't you rather have an electric
truck how much are they wouldn't you
rather have an electric truck [__] no
why would I want an electric truck what
are you talking about
what [__] hoses I don't know you
can't you can't carry anything with
those things they lose their charge so
fast
grocery bags dude that's it [__] that I
want to haul real [__]
I don't even know what I I mean it's
nice to just be able to move [__] like
if I remember one of my most
embarrassing moments I was I was a truck
guy for a long time then I get a Mini
Cooper I'm at Ikea with Nikki and she
wants to get a coffee table and I'm like
we have to go get your car now it's not
gonna fit it
that was a low Point yeah so there's no
name change that you would be too
ashamed to have
wrappers pretty good I think butt [__]
would actually give me some advantages
in life would you change your name to
Steven Ford Coppola
yeah
that's honestly because it's so cringy
ah damn it yeah yeah you know I like
that the other end yeah because then
people are like oh God and I'm like and
I'm like yeah I'm the hardest person to
get man like you're not you're [__]
Bulletproof would you change it to
Epstein
Stephen
Epstein Island
all of these are just great trolls like
you guys could be My Writers because
everyone's gonna be like yo this guy's
connected and he's gonna love that
attention but and that's like the
internet's loose like maybe the dumbest
people on the Earth internet sluice are
like I think he's connected to FCI
this can't be a coincidence Steve
Epstein Island yeah we have to look into
this guy if you had to and you only have
two choices you're either Jeffrey
Epstein Jr
or Adolf Hitler Jr who would you Epstein
Junior for sure for sure dude imagine
your your Adolf junior bro Edom Jr
that's great no it's crazy though I I
heard before like the Hitler name was
pretty common and then after him it's
been so like people that were were like
[__] this dude we're gonna change our
last names
no one that wants to name their kid
Jeffrey now
what show would you rather watch
Epstein Junior Jeffrey Epstein Jr or
Adolf Hitler Jr
because that because that show he's
gonna be way more interesting yeah yep
and what's the premise
is it just Hitler's son and him growing
up [__] growing up in the world and it
feels like there's less kids harmed in
the show yeah yeah yeah cause it's just
him and then versus Jeffrey Epstein Jr
it's like ah and then and then there's a
there's like a little bit of drama right
because then like his teacher in class
sees him writing and she's like what are
you writing
are you writing over there
you're not you don't have to change
Steve Green but you have to add this in
the middle and it's going to be your
writer's Guild name it's going to be
what they credit you for all your movies
Steve White lives matter green
there's no other choice that's it that's
it it's gonna be in quotations on the
credits of everything you [__] do if
you're gonna go down you might as well
go down and style him you mean you're
doing your first movie on black history
another another added another added in
it's the it's the it's the white fist
Emoji yeah
can I keep on putting myself
every time I hand another paper I put
myself
foreign